okay okay finally got this [ __ ] to work
spend an all [ __ ] day changing from
[ __ ] OBS to movavi okay recording
software and this [ __ ] has been a
headache I got my brain is [ __ ]
leakin like blood and [ __ ] and the make
matters worse on the [ __ ] in drink a
dunkin donuts iced coffee without a
straw and I seem like a [ __ ] Savage
anyways we're gonna continue enough
about that psycho [ __ ] uh it looks like
you're doing a little train ride a
little choo-choo um yeah so let's just
see what happens and we'll do a little
recap of the last episode previously on
The Walking Dead get the gates open
we've got wounded I want to know why you
thought bringing more mouths to feed was
a good idea you've been good to me in my
meeting you saved duck from those i
monster sounds and you stood up to Larry
the drunk [ __ ] I won't forget that no
one's trying to cut you out of anything
those look like the people who rated
myself down you're paranoid [ __ ] you me
did you tell anyone out there who you
were or that you were tied to this place
that's right I know who you are and I
know you're a killer he's not dead
somebody help me come on we know this
guy's not gonna make it ah I thought we
did a reverse her car is a shitload of
food and supplies back here you're right
we shouldn't take this the rest of us
are taking this stuff don't worry little
girl and it's got their eye on that
Darren as long as they keep getting food
from them you be safe hmm um and we
destroyed that Dario again we destroyed
it oh okay um oh well I love custom
tailors
okay okay let's do this let's do this
okay like okay an association with
skybound okay the walking dead okay
let's do this walking is important for
help so no it's so scary Oh get how can
it keeps us like facial hair so shrimp
episode three long road ahead all right
all right looks like this is our lucky
day yes it's empty maybe you know maybe
hey they tend to take us by surprise
yeah like what less I see the happy Ryan
what dreams take mesa by surprise often
attempts tools good place the shop
what's up let's chill out here ahead
initial cramps Lee where do you come
down on staying or going you mean
packing up the low tail and getting in
the RV yeah we've been talking about it
but you made up your mind yet hmm we
should go we should go motels run its
course it's not safe you damn right it
is and it's your pros I went to the RV
and don't pull over till we see water
and if Lily's dead set on staying then
well that's the way it goes thank you
Eric Parsons for directing okay just
like last time over the rig into the
pharmacy and scraped together whatever
supplies are left we didn't leave much
engine Bell we're out of options
somethings better than nothing there's
gonna be some violence here they love
opening with violence i can't imagine
episode ah [ __ ] you okay the ladders
come loose I'm not sure how many more
trips she's got in her I'm not sure how
many more trips we've gotten us go
sailing and Izzy brother say it like it
is not shade even heard of sucking like
watch us for me hilarious
Thanks looks like she's had it what now
I'll find another way up I'm better get
a move on I'm [ __ ] of resourceful I'm
gonna look at the sparrow go though I
love looking a barrel hmm yeah same way
uh-uh puts the cheap takip I got the
winch it Lily's not doing so good huh oh
yeah kill their dad well we killed her
dad we did kill xjet stress all true
statements okay yeah that's a tat yet I
am one a resourceful [ __ ] kids don't
use that word all right look at the sign
Everett's prescriptions
mm-hmm yep did you say anything else ok
let's winch this thing together
your girls still upset with me for
taking stuff out of that car last week
I haven't asked just gonna let it stew
huh
it's a good thing
did make this game pretty um pretty
interesting on the fact that even if
it's erased asking about the I
Herschel's farm last night like not
taking the free luton the coat was huge
a dress to fit her perfectly of course
it did it was a scary situation for him
Sean dying at all I'm just worried he'll
always think it was his fault and that
is his fault yeah sure you up for this
Lee I'm fine I've got its mustanger he's
good he's good yes real nice one next
time I'm bringing Ben help me get up
what the [ __ ] somebody yeah what the
hell is that a water walkers don't side
with a Jesus I think so
it's a girl we have to help with how you
know getting to her we gotta do
something sure put her out of this
mission over here what do you mean with
me we leave her alive she drives him out
to find us to think about where I was
worrying about the ones we can't see she
stays alive and brings me out of their
holes good point thank you because
hopefully doesn't drag out your debts
alone
thanks for watching oh yeah it don't
matter all right if anyone wants the
action this is gonna dry out the action
you can have you alone Jason Hanukkah is
to achievement goodbye she quietly says
okay Mannix so going we should be good
to clear this place out but we ain't got
all day get everything you can out of
these racks don't forget underneath the
counter this time all clear down here
and then we gotta go hey lady oh yeah I
guess you
see they try and [ __ ] punish us but
this is something that they cannot
punish for auditory just like a speaking
roses she's gone there's not much time
now we get all the items
I think that's everything oh [ __ ]
they're right there a bottle didn't die
for nothing then up and over thank
goodness still here let's hustle Oh
white [ __ ]
Louis
yes i love
[ __ ] to get out get ya Scott
not too much let's go pal can't you get
set my dig at NHS yet
like this minimalist music get out of
here fly because I'm [ __ ] flies me
I'm so sad but wait till I be the hero
with all this food
I'm so glad that one later we killed
wasn't hurt your back then found some
stickers in a drawer and I put him on my
watch yeah hey sweet pea that's neat
I'll find you the man
wait till your dad gets home hears about
this I can't looks like we got the kid
on watch again would you get might as
well leave a sign out that says the men
are going come and rape our women and
children mean huh so what did you get
good stuff a lot of stuff
we're fine by the way nice work this
will keep us going if we carry on like
this we'll get through the winter here
the winter will freeze our asses off
here he's piling into an RV with you two
after what you did to my dad is so
appealing why wouldn't it be you know
i'll do what it takes to keep everyone
safe we're already safe we have to go a
[ __ ] ass hey I don't have to do
anything you didn't want to go because
your dad's health but he's gone now easy
Kenny Wu at it again are we can it Carly
sorry don't boss people around I'm sorry
buddy needs to make executive decisions
for the group doe I don't think you're
capable or not we're strongest together
I can't be you versus us left why is
suffer for what happened to your dad but
we're in this together now what about
the food situation what about protection
what about when this place falls
somebody's got to be thinking about this
[ __ ] how has this not been working we
have everything we mean to me Lily
that's beat as Kenny and you we got
plenty of food from that station wagon
you didn't even want to take it where
the hell would we be now we can't just
keep our fingers crossed for more
station wagons and it's true everything
that happens to us is another excuse for
you to pull this crap about leaving all
I want is a week of peace of not hearing
it do you know how we got these supplies
we got lucky and let a girl get eaten
out look you gotta bring red hot some
girl came screaming out of an alley she
had her head hanging although
clementines like she gave us enough time
to get everything we could out of the
drugstore and you just let her suffer
like what like bait
god what is happening she was dead
anyway I paint the most sense in the
moment Lee's right we've been putting
our lives on the line doing these runs
into the city you wouldn't believe the
[ __ ] we see we all appreciate it can you
should be thanking Lee for not shooting
that girl it's not so easy for him look
can I candidates people aren't say Laura
it's not a town it's full of walkers and
the people can just lay dying and
wandering out onto the streets it's hell
on earth and it's coming this way it's
not going to be easier out on the road
how would you know what I know I know
you're not a buffer der I know somebody
has been stealing our supplies that's
right stealing and I know the list of
people I can trust your gets smaller
every day going creo everybody get out
since table
she'll get over it she's riling
everybody up otherwise you understand we
all have to she's right about work out
her not like there's any easier pick him
with everyone else except her she's
really kind of crazy so
can't hit the [ __ ] spill the beans
about that girl Jesus well things are
coming to a head give me a good sailor I
mean sorry that's what well I think you
did good today and I find myself
thinking that most yes yes yes but
thanks girl it's probably worth
following up with Lily about what she
was saying about missing son yes with
her wound up the way she is I don't want
to see her paranoid no question and I'd
like to talk when you've got a minute no
sous right now baby hey you gotten a bit
you're warming that parka and I'm cold
follow me upstairs he and I got a little
early I'm gonna climb the stairs
talk to Lily yet Nomad yeah we just
thought were that
what I wanted to say was I've been
thinking a lot about you
anything about you to think about you
too
our group is small you're a small
hmm
you're convicted killer Carly Jesus and
I think people should know not because
they deserve to and not because you're a
bad man I think the opposite of those
two things
people need to know because we're
hanging by a thread here and I can't see
Lily talk about you without thinking
it's the next thing she's going to say
you don't have to tell everyone but
think about who you trust take the
opportunity while you have it your ID
your pepper area probably right course
I'm probably right people might be
pissed and telling them might cause some
trouble but it will be a far cry from
what will happen if they don't hear it
from you that's true yeah amazed will do
it so you'll do it then yeah
I'll let people know it totally right
good I think it's for the best
oh she gonna kiss him kiss him kiss him
yes don't call me small
baby I don't baby now is there anything
else you want to talk about
do you feel safe here show me to bath
with a heated floor and a high-rise
apartment and pan me a full-bodied
malbec and then I'll feel safe I don't
know that this place is fine but we all
know that that could change it okay
and we're gonna look into this thing
good idea I guess I forgot to tell some
people telling people how it is Hannah
like a climbdown airiness I'm gonna
catch you take it easy I guess by take
both of my hey you two how are you doing
we're okay just having a little spat
what we all carry guns now and I don't
like it it's the way it's gotta be I
know but I'm not getting used to it I'm
sorry how are you Lee um you got you
free to talk to you about something sure
is everything okay hmm is he gonna
wonder why I was uh on my way to prison
three months ago all right you've always
looked at me with kind eyes I wonder if
you could still do that if you knew I
was a convicted felon my goodness for
what how much trouble can a teacher get
into [ __ ] well plenty but it had nothing
to do with that it was for murder oh why
he and my wife that's enough tell me
what happened when you were locked in
the fridge at the dairy hell bunny back
Kenny made sure Larry didn't get up [ __ ]
what did he do he smashed his head in oh
[ __ ] oh oh [ __ ]
gotcha everything keeps changing yeah
well I you know it's honest with her you
know he is a good policy i think she
done in the beginning I guess but right
hi guys kidney you got a second I need
to tell you something sure pal well you
got hmm he says my bro uh-huh Carly in
service oh no what the she-devil do to
you shut up man I was uh on my way to
prison three months ago no [ __ ] no [ __ ]
he's like I figure that it wasn't for
touching kids once it's all makeup man
what I gotta ask no I killed a guy in a
fight oh [ __ ] hmm must have been a real
piece of [ __ ] if you had to haul off and
kill him so we'll straight there wow
that was so easy we look at everything
this mess has got us doing now I'm sorry
you went through whatever you went
through yeah we're straight wow that's
good i'm happy about that one [ __ ] i
thought that one would go south okay
okay oh yes hanging a good nuts hey bid
what's up Lee hey Ben I need to tell you
something surely is it about my watch
I'm trying to do a good job you're doing
fine I was on my way to prison huh say I
have it is brother whoa seriously what
um were you in for it's not important oh
just if you hear anything it's probably
true and now you know huh oh thanks for
trusting me man I uh relax okay I like
Ben
she's not gonna [ __ ] forget that oh
nothing here nothing here okay I guess I
just where's duck [ __ ] the app it's like
I just like the [ __ ] with her yeah I get
up your piece of slime I'm sorry you
don't have to apologize did you come in
here he give me hell or to coddle me I
wanted to follow up on what you said
about stolen supplies do you know what's
going on I don't just heard you mention
it and you came in here to confess I'm
not stealing [ __ ] I came in here to help
cuz there's a traitor somebody one of us
out there he or she or they have been
taking things
for real who what do you got yes for
real I don't have [ __ ] I just know Lily
counts off and it's the good stuff
antibiotics oxy [ __ ] anything with opium
in it nope not and it's fine I keep my
own that one's getting messed with I'm a
[ __ ] mess right now but I'm not
stupid I know what happens if I start a
witch yeah so you want me to start one I
want you to poke around all right damn
brothers gotta do this is it go on oh
it's cuz that's hat I found this tossed
into the garbage hmm we don't toss out
equipment we fix it you'd only try to
get rid of a flashlight if you're using
it when you shouldn't okay okay I'll
poke around a little bit thank you if
you don't find anything I'm just going
to assume it's you what a bit a mystery
Jesus doc I'm sorry I heard you guys
talking you need to unhear all of that
can I help what did I just say I could
use him your other grace detective and I
can be Dick Grayson your ward mmm that's
Robin I know who it is in that you can
help don't tell anybody secrecy yeah
good if it's can't answer let's do I
don't know go look around and let me
know if you find anything weird I'm on
the case oh I like that little [ __ ]
somebody's going around breaking
flashlights and I gotta go see this girl
time to kiss her Kenneth take what's
mine I talked to Kenny about Who I am
and it was cool he just worries about
his family that wasn't so hard was it
tough guy
I talk to Katya how'd she take it she
was fine i guess i think she's more
upset about Kinney because of the st.
John's what exactly did he do back there
don't you start now
I told Ben you told Ben or finer you
pick him no risk
I take it he didn't know what to do with
the information not even a little he's
just happy I told him something
do you know anything about this
flashlight expression it's broken I
don't know what's broken and the
batteries might be in backwards
it uses just one everything should what
was the question did you break the
flashlight no okay
I'll talk to you later huh I'll talk to
you later she's amazing she's amazing I
hope she doesn't have like big boyfriend
yet though
hey Clementine Haley you didn't
accidentally break a flashlight did you
know did duck see I did know did a duck
break the flashlight I don't think so
he's just always blaming me for stuff
like what putting a bug on his pillow
did you do that yes what a cool girl
[ __ ] and I thought the can yet but Kenny
do you guys know anything about this
broken flashlight [ __ ] we don't got many
of those yeah it's a problem the glass
and the bull bar all busted up I saw
some broken glass over by the ice
machine I meant to clean it up before
the kids hurt themselves on it I forgot
though ok ok I can work with that should
show him real quick yeah might as well
the flashlight was broken was it you
know you're not in trouble if it was I
know you get nervous and maybe you went
out to go to the bathroom broke it got
worried and tossed it what's with the
third degree I didn't break any
flashlights ok there [ __ ] I am tough I
wait you tough I broke it I fabric it
and can't there's some broken glass on
the ground mmm that is the truth brother
yeah I'm inspect that oh yeah somebody
was here pulling with a class 0 and x
marks the spot there's something drawn
it looks like a intersection
Oh pink hmm dark a clue me I bet it's
like a signal Gideon bandits I bet thing
I don't think it's anything maybe it's a
sign it could be it's pink chalk which
is weird ok back to investigating who
has the pink chalk it's not my
Clementine she's too cute for that right
climate sign what about the Chuck that
Chuck right there hey Clementine Haley
do uh you have any pink chalk no it's
gone somewhere hmm do you want blue no
no it's okay me I found something what
is it I found this piece of pink chalk
and a scuff of it over by the gate
really totally I was calling a scene for
clues yeah duck I got it good job
alright cool you didn't break the
flashlight did you duck no mom and dad
want me touching their stuff well don't
easily guy from Toy Story likely he
probably for the best hey fascinating
surely fascinating all right anything
with this chalk eyes the old chalk
breakers have you seen any chalk around
oh yes Clementine loves to draw his ship
yeah she says she's missing a piece of
it well I don't know anything about that
like a sock shrunken when this got real
[ __ ] to work or not ducky play with
chalk hey Ben I need a piece of chalk
you know where I can get any why would I
have any just asking around well I don't
play with that stuff I've got my well my
thoughts and I've been reading the Bible
I found in my room that's what it's
there for okay talk about lowly I guess
hey find anything
hmm I'll be back ok let's find out about
this chalk situation for my girl yeah
you play with chalk here did you live in
ear chalk I can borrow what Clementine
holding out on you so you don't have any
no why would I
[ __ ] is a dead end
the only one left that is it stuck long
touchdown hey Clementine Hayley creo I
need to talk to you for a second okie
dokie the day you and I met I was in a
car accident I remember your leg was
bleeding the car I was in was a police
car and I was on my way to jail for
committing a crime who I need to tell
you now because I don't want you to hear
it any other way okay do you have
anything to say I don't think so you can
go home back to your things all right
let me just tell her that dope
Clementine so I basically told everyone
except like she's like unstable
I talked to Clementine about things
how'd she handle it
I don't know she's tough to read she
adores you don't worry
okay you see you [ __ ] I talk to you
left Tom talk to Kenny just talked to
Kenny and see what they have to say
about the guns don't you start I just
wanted to say cat it's probably good
they make you uncomfortable thank you e
but we need them there's no doubt about
that you need to try harder with Lily
you guys gotta straighten this up I
don't know how straight we can get it
given all that's happened mm-hmm so what
did Tom will come we'll have to do
what's best for our families and that's
what was it that's the truth we got to
get rid of that [ __ ] you guys trust
everyone here more or less I obviously
have my problems with Lily but I don't
distrust that again yeah we can't turn
on each other any more than we have I'll
talk to you later mm-hmm let's talk to
Ben have you seen anything weird on what
is there anybody out there up to
anything nope really quiet really yeah
totally which is good what do you think
about liberation she scares the crap out
of me that's a reasonable thing to feel
you I'm just worried she's going to snap
yeah we got to get rid of her talk to
you later Ben by who's gonna hate me but
I gotta get rid of anyone that's like a
wrongdoer you know a wrongdoer hmm
definitely weird
okay my what am I missing here it can't
just be your coincidence okay it's got
to be like a point somewhere here maybe
there's like something in the trash or I
can't go over there look for the RV
sounds like Kenny actually has that
thing running I don't believe it when I
see it hello jokester okay okay
nothing's here nothing's here you check
the other side huh yes I'll just tell
Lily hey find anything I'm gonna tell
you something I need to tell you
something what is it push off the edge I
killed someone before all of this you
think that's news I guess I hoped it was
worse did you think that story died with
my dad anything else no no [ __ ] okay
okay all right that's all bad solder
I told Lily
you were right she and Larry spoke
obviously
it went about as well as you would
expect
you uh have any thoughts about living I
worry about her that's about it she
keeps trying to run things but it's just
not working
okay now are there any other clue
markers any other clue markers dr.
Palantine what's that you working on
Clem it's called a leaf rubbing my
teacher Miss Moore showed us how to do
them when we went to the Botanical
Garden one hey nice hey nice see it's
the same um kind of that's really
something I'll make one for you to UM do
oh it's gone somewhere hmm do you want
blue no no it's okay do you like it here
hey don't like it here do you want to be
your canal on we got a job to get that
gesture I don't know maybe if I knew
where yeah I'd be a good thing to know
I'll talk to you later clin okay okay
real any [ __ ] we're stuck hiding ducks
the one that has like all the news i
guess i just talked to him have you
found anything else just the chuck i
also found some bugs underneath the
stairs don't tell Clinton okay okay I
won't niacin you seem to know a bit
about all of this the chalk you found
the scuff here this is gonna sound crazy
but you're not involved are you know I'm
a good guy stay inside the gate oh well
I will okay anything if I go this way no
Sam oh I think I gotta talk to Kenny
highly highly that's it hi Evan weeks
avz
what the heck am I missing oh wait back
up I saw something oh wait hopscotch
Carson dog's favorite mmm man you gotta
add things do you ever come down here to
make it much I didn't have much reason
to my parents would let me take the car
into the city on the weekend but what's
in macon it's kind of a waste of time
compared to a head I grew up in Macon oh
I didn't mean to say it's crappy or
anything it's super nice I mean not now
but I bet it was is talk to you later
babe bye let's see here there's
something that's gotta be more clues
flashlight did I talk to everyone about
the flashlight I feel like cooking class
chalk no more stories with him I bet
it's like Lily duck got no more stuff
hey find anything do you ever want to
leave here I want to leave here when we
have to not because of some fantasy of
somewhere better so you think the coast
is a pipe dream don't you we're going to
live on the water because we assume they
can't swim we're alive because we've
stayed here that's as far as the
discussion needs to go this [ __ ] all
right I'm just gonna check the [ __ ]
date or duck is duction be just like
[ __ ] standing there I just scanned the
whole wall for [ __ ] points but it's
there yeah that or there's something
like high up anything here now how can I
go over here anything over here no you
think did me safe oh there's been
chopped right here Jesus Christ so
[ __ ] just had he [ __ ] her stack Oh
he founded that somebody was over here
to see I did good huh yeah duck you did
I suppose I should go out there and look
around you stay here this guy seriously
ok I don't think what the [ __ ] are they
opening it ok ok we'll see what's gone
I'll see what's going on ok you can't
look at fence I can't go that far at
school we just get all the way to the
right great yeah it's the great those
bandits gave us hair but they've been
quiet for days now there's a great down
there are you getting in that way cuz
that'd be [ __ ] up oh [ __ ] I wonder if
that's the [ __ ]
stuff yeah some of [ __ ] Kenshin you
salute I trust bandage too much I'm
scared again you haven't come up with
anything have you I came up with this
it's got a bunch of meds in it it was in
a great on the outside wall and there's
a sign on the other one holy [ __ ] yeah
okay we line everybody up everybody
somebody's killing us stealing from that
supply is the same as slipping into your
room at night and cutting your throat
while you sleep time what is the
difference what if Clementine gets sick
and we don't have what we need she's all
crazy what the hell you know [ __ ]
steal from us who the [ __ ] is that young
happy pill out there [ __ ] we [ __ ]
around what do we do oh [ __ ] you're
gonna start kicking in doors any second
what the hell are you darlin what just
keep him talking do whatever it takes to
stop him pulling a trigger okay made the
biggest mistake yo la [ __ ]
enough of this [ __ ] true stop
putting your boot to these doors yeah
move it [ __ ] take it easy why are you
doing this just leave us the [ __ ] alone
why it's [ __ ] guy why because we
canna that's why um what will it take to
reach a deal about twice as much as
you've been giving up you got it done is
that so well I suppose we ought to hash
out some terms in I don't like no hair
and [ __ ] cries [ __ ] I got a beard oh
[ __ ] it's a popo get him there smoke him
out [ __ ] we gotta get out of here no
[ __ ] those bastards cover our people
would get under the RV
go round [ __ ] for bringing back there
let's
now get over here hurry you have me Seto
get it thought kids up fool oh [ __ ]
badger oh my god
gotcha hurry come on click get inside
the RV it's gonna be okay Joe Christ
look like i say ducking her again let me
get in the RV screwer let her stay
ok
yeah nothing my chance get out of here
Jesus cat Jesus are you okay I'm fine
I'm fine [ __ ] who shadows I'm sorry
everything's fine everything's not fine
we need to figure out how this happened
you just lost everything well we're
lucky as [ __ ] to have this RV nobody
died can't already done I'm fine
somebody in here cause this settle down
back there the bandits have had our
number four weeks this is different
somebody was working for them whoever it
was was flipping them are met they
didn't get their last package so they
attacked calm down back there that's
nuts we found a bag of supplies hidden
outside the wall hmm it's true so Carly
is there something I like to the wrong
place please we have to get it out of
you then back off you're in no position
to make demands whoa whoa whoa you're
just pointing fingers Holly's trust way
snot a traitor Lily Thank You Lee she
can fight her own battles unless there's
something going on here that implicates
we gotta get real well II don't be
ridiculous like look maybe we should
devote or something like that both what
just look something like a fan of gallon
maybe this was all just to miss let me
stop waving the finger at everybody we
know something's going on and we can get
to the bottom of it if we keep our head
know what we found lily is batshit crazy
I know nobody was stealing anything was
it both of you what I've seen you two
together was it both of you oh look just
let me out I didn't do it but I don't
like this I don't like where it's headed
look me in the eyes and tell me you
didn't have anything to do with it Lily
lay off of him I
[ __ ] going on up there I had something
we gotta stop well we can deal with this
now better
Kenny is it safe should be everybody out
early out we gotta leave low behind I
like how really been didn't say anything
you trust where they may be the panic
scared
Oh bet like some was gonna happen is
gonna cause like a time crunch doesn't
matter i make this can t be RV has some
surface damage but there's a walker
trapped underneath god damn it everyone
keep your eyes peeled you know what we
shouldn't just kick you out we should
hear what everybody thinks I think you
should chill out I'm not gonna take this
you can push been around but you can't
push me around I'm really sorry feel
that way I'm starting to think maybe it
was both of you there's no way it was
calling somebody else it could have even
been somewhat sneaking into our can
that's ridiculous that's what you think
yes okay fine then Kenny I don't know
[ __ ] just stop would you well your vote
counts for you and cautious mrs. we
don't need all these votes what do I
have to do for you to trust me I'll do
anything oh all they watch us for months
huh the hell you will I'll get more food
more medicine anything stop panicking
seriously big you need to stop and just
take a breath do we need any more
evidence than this [ __ ] evidence stop
treating him like a shot on Carly oh
I've heard enough out of you Kenny
what's it gonna be just give me a damn
minute then you have until that Walker
is dealt with to tell me it was her and
not you stop this you're torturing him
no man stop this is about trust and I've
never trusted you look
they are I can't leave you know I can't
thank you lee please listen to him he's
don't kick me out of the group we will
tell me now hey I got a piece let's just
get back that not happening you think
you're so hot cinch don't you like
nothing can hurt you it's you're just a
scared little girl we got Gary Locke
over it take a page from Lee's book and
try helping somebody for once she's
quite insane don't say now guns give me
the [ __ ] the problem no [ __ ] way no
[ __ ] way she can drop it no [ __ ]
way Oh Kenny what's up you talk away
from the windows Jesus Christ no [ __ ]
get in we're leaving this crazy [ __ ]
she couldn't be trusted Lee I swear
leave you're not coming with us I'll die
out here I don't care you're a murderer
Lily we can't have you with us I'm a
murderer you Hadley with you this
full-time care what he did before if we
keep you with us how long until you get
me I was trying to protect all of us
yeah well you [ __ ] up I don't have
anything left get in li let's go you
guys
[ __ ] [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] eat
my shorts [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
girlfriend yeah she's not gonna make it
big chubbies meeting that was the most
fun thing every word please
that was so [ __ ] up
she says
what's up
is stuck feeling all right
wait I bet catch a [ __ ] took the meds
what far she's got that happened during
the raid
what's the plan they've never had a bite
victim in a group before
I'm going to keep an eye on him and see
what I can do from a medical perspective
we keep the same plan unless something
changes East guys what else is there to
do we thought you should know all right
important to stay honest with each other
yeah that's true Thank gather anyway if
you could tell Clementine we would
appreciate it all right all right
actually I'm gonna want to pause this
here actually [ __ ] is just hit the
[ __ ] fan I'm going to pause it here
alright hope you guys enjoy hope you
guys enjoy